pupil Referral Units or crews are places
for children who've been excluded from
mainstream education Langdon Hills in
Basildon is considered a good one by
Ofsted but many of the children here are
troubled what doesn't kill you makes
wish you dead yep she has some dark
moments yeah do sometimes see clues to
what's going on in their lives yes the
art teacher says kids here need empathy
when they say they're scared I'm scared
about going home or can they leave 10
minutes early because you know some
adults might say oh well that's just
them trying to get out of school it
might be but it might actually be that
they really hit someone waiting out
there with a baseball bat
some children clearly need the expertise
offered here but England's Peru
population has increased by 10 percent
in two years to nearly 17-thousand and
the Children's Commissioner is worried
that for many it's a route into gangs we
know that in some PR use the percentage
of children who are in gangs is high
sometimes it's 50% someone told me the
other day that if they counted the
children who also run the drugs then
it's as high as 80% it's easier for
gangs to be able to access vulnerable
children if they're all in one place so
in my view they need to remain as far as
possible within the mainstream school
earlier this year this map mysteriously
appeared all over the northern line
illustrating how children in pupil
Referral Units are four times more
likely to end up in prison this activist
put them up there's a path that anybody
can take the schools will be like ah
you're not operating well here you have
to be excluded and then from there there
it's that self-fulfilling prophecy that
they're not good enough and then they
just leads them down the wrong road Sky
News has found that across the country
hundreds of children are unofficially
moving down this route that some schools
are effectively under reporting the
level of exclusions by doing what's
called off rolling off rolling is where
a child is unofficially excluded and
taken off the school's register and
there's a spike in the number of these
cases in year ten the year before
children sit GCSEs meaning their results
won't count towards the school and
that's led to accusations that the
schools are in part their
or motivated to do this to improve their
own results look at this it's the
Department of Education exclusion map it
suggests red areas places like
Lancashire and Bedford have the biggest
problems with exclusions but it is
misleading for example in just 10 of the
local authorities marked here in white
there were 750 unofficial exclusions
where children were off rolled and
taking their GCSEs in pupil Referral
Units without being officially excluded
children have many more rights if
they're actually permanently excluded
Ofsted tracks them if they're
permanently excluded they have to be
offered a place within a certain number
of days if they're permanently excluded
if they're informally excluded that
isn't the case and what we see is a
spike of X of informal exclusions or off
rolling has often talked about in year
10 11 often when children are reaching
the GCSEs here were two examples of what
can happen when Kieren was unofficially
excluded he disappeared from the
education system altogether my friends
like what permanently exclude they told
me they had this board me in a round
table and things like that none of that
happened I was just told not to come
back into school and I need to go to
this place well I didn't end up going
there because of the area that it was in
and and the corner and some country that
I was in at the time so I didn't go to
their own proof so I kind of just stayed
on the street hung out of people was
exposed to a lot of things a lot of bad
things nehemiah went to approve but he
believes the children in them are
increasingly at risk I'm still very in
touch with one of my t-shirts if since
he works out to prove and he just tells
me is it's getting worse every year is
getting worse he's had two deaths two
student died over the period of last
summer which is shocking killed killed
yet local authorities we've approached
say Prue's act as safe havens for
students with complex medical and
emotional needs some areas identify
students who would most benefit from the
program offered by a Prue and sometimes
it's part of a managed move from one
mainstream school to another
but others say schools are often
offloading children due to a lack of
resources I think there's some anecdotal
evidence emerging that in
parts of the country where school
secondary schools in particular feel
they're not being adequately supported
that they are sometimes finding
mechanisms where they can take the
children off role parents are being
asked if they will agree to home
education as opposed to permanent
exclusion that is sweeping the problem
under the carpet you have to be so
empathetic without that empathy that
young person would just be like yeah
just give up on me like like everyone
else and that's what leads to to
exclusion that's what leads to you
violence that's what leads to young
people doing the wrong things or confide
in or spending time with the wrong
people because that wrong person give
them the time or day the Department of
Education told us exclusions should only
ever be used as a last resort
the government has recently launched an
external review looking at how
exclusions I use Jason Farrell Sky News